alternatiba santé veut montrer qu'il ya
des alternatives au niveau de la santé
le film aborde l'alimentation est de
montrer que notre santé on va pas un
tout le monde sait que nos amis chinois
la médecine chinoise passant par là que
la santé est forcément grand par une
grande partie lié à ce que l'on mange
donc le film aborde la place de
l'alimentation dans notre santé par un
exemple qui s'est passé dans une ville
du sud où une ville a décidé de passer
ses cantines au bio et on voit les
petits croche-pied qui a eu pour mettre
tout ça en place et le réalisateur lui a
fait ce film là parce qu'elle a eu aussi
des problèmes de santé il s'est rendu
compte que tous les cochonneries les
produits chimiques et on va pas en faire
des tonnes sont magnifiquement présent
dans nos assiettes et c'est pas pour
nous faire du bien donc il a fait un
film militant sur cette expérience de
cette ville du sud